recall the latest moves even though I'm
sure he can but there you go he's done
his homework Ivanka King G6 on the board
he's still in preparation this is the
only move studying chairs and just
ingraining those patterns into his
memory bank and there we can see very
bashing out Rook to E7
it's most likely to end in a draw even
though I can't see how this position
would ever end in a draw
but they think okay I'm gonna play it
anyway because there's a great chance
that my opponent might not remember
things perfectly and you know there's
only one move here as well that black
can play it's it's bizarre there's only
one move in look in this position look
at Yan I love I love his facial
um moves here and his favorite move
immediately Bishop F4 uh this is move 29
and they're banging out their Moves In
This highly complex position I mean what
a crazy position Ivanka is and he's and
look at that vidis banged out his next
move whoa and Yan looking very confused
there this is this is great stuff look
at that face Ricky's six whoa and yeah
you know you're he's obviously thinking
why can I not just go King takes Knight
well you know what king takes Knight is
the only move and then Whiteside there
is G3 and you know what I'm the father
of Ivanka I am not just the father of
dragons
I'm the father of Harry the H porn and
Harry H Pawn will then be threatening to
go check mate visits is gonna decide
yep he uh is accepting the draw and
there we see the handshake and it is a
draw in the first tiebreak encounter